I mean
let's be honest the doctor would be on
the picket line
hey folks so this today's video was
going to be something else but instead
it's going to be this I want to talk
about Doctor Who the SAG aftra and wga
strike and how that is going to impact
the future of this channel here's the
quick bullet points I have been trying
to figure out for a little while whether
or not Doctor Who is considered to be
under the strike order of these two
unions now I've talked about the wga
strike I've talked about the psych after
strike I am in support of both these
things now the research that I had
leaned towards Doctor Who not being
under the strike order because it's shot
in the UK with UK based companies and
falls under equity for it most of its
Union work at least as far as actors go
and Equity is not striking so
my leaning was I think it's going to be
okay well
that turned out to not be the case I
have a friend on Tick Tock
um whose account I will link down there
she's a cosplayer and that was uh the
main way that she reached out directly
to sagafter and actually got a direct
answer from them I never heard back
um I might have been trying to reach
through the wrong channels or maybe they
haven't gotten to me yet I don't know
but um she wanted to hear back in terms
of the status of Doctor Who specifically
because she is actually very well known
as a 13th Doctor cosplayer she's
incredibly good at it
um she's got the voice down perfect but
this was what she got back
so
Doctor Who is considered to fall under
the strike order now this correspondence
which I have because she made it public
does not specifically say why
if I were to guess and I'm going to it's
most likely because of the money that is
involved in it from Studios that fall
under the strike order
and those two Studios being Disney and
Sony a reminder that Sony owns bad wolf
Studios where the production for Doctor
Who is happening and Disney is throwing
in a big chunk of money into at the very
least the marketing if not the
production budget in order to be able to
carry the show on Disney plus now
before people get confused on this this
does not mean that the show is not going
to move forward with its own production
due to the strike that's not what I'm
talking about here I'm talking
specifically about how this is going to
relate to this Channel and I'll get more
into that in a minute but I want to be
clear so far as I can tell because of
what I mentioned earlier about the
actors on the show falling under equity
and the wga I don't even know if there
is an equivalent Union in the UK or not
but there are no striking unions in the
UK so production on the show so far as I
know we'll move forward and not be
interrupted however in terms of
um union members promoting talking about
and the idea of influencers promoting or
talking about for sag-aftra and the
wga's purposes they consider it to be
under the strike order so again I'm not
talking about the production or whether
or not after series 14 more stuff will
be produced or whether that'll be on
hold I don't don't think it will be put
on hold it might but right now we don't
know but that's not what I'm talking
about
I'm selfishly talking about myself and
my own channel
so
what does this mean for the channel
short version
it means no more Doctor Who stuff for as
long as the strike is ongoing
because as I said before I do support
the unions I want to help them as best I
can so
earlier this week you had the top 10
episodes for the 13th Doctor and that is
going to be the last Doctor Who related
video that I do on this channel for the
foreseeable future
and
yeah that's going to be a bit of a shift
now I suspect there's some questions
some folks probably have about certain
things and aspects of this so I'm gonna
kind of
do I guess I'll call it a presumptive
FAQ I don't know if these will be the
frequently asked questions but they're
the ones I'm anticipating but Vera are
you even in the unions no I'm not but as
I said I want to show solidarity to them
and the other factor is you know acting
against the strike order would impede
any potential future admission to those
unions do I have a realistic expectation
that I would ever be eligible to join
either of those unions
no not really but I'm still a creative
person I am an actor I am a writer and
I'd prefer not to have those doors shut
because I didn't stop talking about
Doctor Who that's the more selfish
reason but as I said The more driving
one is solidarity I want to support
these strikes I want both unions to get
what they are asking for or as much of
it as they possibly can and I live on
the other side of the country I can't
join the picket line but I can do this
aren't critics and reviewers exempt sort
of you might have seen or read or heard
from other people on here or other
influencers Etc about the some of the
stuff that has been said with requests
to work not being done by union members
but still impacts things and they uh sag
after in specific has said that they are
not requesting any kind of stop of
critical work or reviews
here's the thing though
I'm not really a Critic I mean Rotten
Tomatoes considers me one and that's
nice but honestly what I do doesn't fall
cleanly under the category of critic you
know somebody writing a review for a
periodical or even just doing a hey I
saw this movie and here's what I thought
but like for a greater organization be
it a TV series a news uh Channel
whatever those are critics what I do
even though I do reviews and critical
work Falls a lot more under the category
of influencer and as someone who
straddles that line between critic and
influencer because ultimately I don't
just do critical stuff I do all manner
of content talking about all sorts of
stuff and not just here on YouTube but
all over the place like as much as I
don't think I fit the typical influencer
template or what most people think of
when they hear that term that is
ultimately a more accurate description
of what I am and what I do and they are
asking influencers to not do anything
that could be considered promotional
work now I had already kind of stopped
doing review content partly out of
solidarity and partly out of an
abundance of caution because while it is
certainly possible that maybe it would
be okay for me to do reviews like my
position as either a critic or an
influencer and exactly where I fall in
that is so nebulous like it just feels
like a better idea for me to just
cleanly go I probably shouldn't do that
right now can you still talk about
classic Doctor Who
no so even though you might think that a
strike is only for upcoming and to be
released work the thing is Doctor Who as
a property is under the strike order so
talking about classic Doctor Who which I
do enjoy doing is something that could
still be considered promotional because
it brings attention to the property
overall even though it I'd be talking
about stuff from decades ago this is the
same reason why
um starting not this coming Monday but
the Monday after the jump gate podcast
that I do with Jesse gender talking
about Babylon 5 is going to go on hiatus
because Babylon 5 though it is a show
from the 90s is still a live property it
has an animated direct to DVD movie
coming out and it is owned by Warner
Brothers discovery which is a studio
under the strike order so uh if you are
a podcast listener don't worry the
podcast feed is not going away you'll
set up new stuff on Mondays it's just
going to be stuff that we can um talk
about because also to be clear when it
comes to like avoiding review material
it's not strictly speaking all review
material it's reviews of things that are
owned or
um possibly even in part owned with
something like Doctor Who just because
of the money mixed in
um from Studios that are being struck
against but that is primarily affecting
the major Studios with headquarters in
the U.S so that is not going to impact
certain things so on say the break room
of Geeks you might start seeing more
stuff related to
uh wow I need to comb through what
commissions I've got waiting but
um Independent films theoretically anime
video games and it'll still be a review
material but it won't be on properties
that are under the strike order which
unfortunately I now know Doctor Who is
as is Babylon 5. what about non-review
stuff like the lists you do that
actually is a much cleaner answer that's
an absolute no so it was actually the
reviews that were the most nebulous
because if I wanted to try and make an
argument that I am a Critic which
I don't think I can make that argument I
do criticism and I do reviews but I'm an
influencer ultimately but that was kind
of nebulous things like listicles and
things like that no that I mean that's
very cleanly something that serves a
promotional purpose not in the sense
that I'm being directly paid by the BBC
or Disney or Sony or anybody else to
make them but it is just going hey let's
talk about this show which serves for
their purposes for the purposes of the
studio is a promotional aspect and that
yeah no that was going to have to stop
kind of regardless at least in terms of
what I knew to be stuff under the strike
order which until recently I didn't know
Doctor Who was but now again I know now
so no Doctor Who then
No Doctor Who
like it
I'm not thrilled
either but like I said I think what the
unions are doing is important and I want
to support it and I want to lend that
support under the guidelines in in terms
of what sag-aftra and the wga are asking
people in positions like mine to do in
order to help them
are you mad or annoyed with other
channels that aren't taking as hard a
line as you on this no
no I'm not
I don't personally know of any channels
that at least that I watch that are
saying they don't support the strike how
they choose to support the strike may
not be the way that I choose to do it
they may ultimately choose not to really
support the strike but honestly unless
they are talking out against it they're
going to do what they're going to do and
as I said some of the decisions that I'm
making are out of an abundance of
caution there are some channels that
what they do particularly in the uh
sphere of Doctor Who there are some who
tubers that's literally all they do
Doctor Who may be the thing I talk about
the most on here
but it's not the only thing I talk about
I can pivot to other topics there are
channels that are built on talking about
nothing other than Doctor Who what the
heck are they supposed to do no I'm not
mad at them I don't think they're wrong
I'm not beefing with them I have friends
people who I genuinely considered
friends who uh consider that sounded
like past tense consider still to be my
friends who are doing Doctor Who related
material or who are doing review work of
stuff that is under the strike order and
I'm not mad at them they're making their
decision I'm making mine so I'm not mad
at anybody and I'm not recommending that
you be mad at anybody what I'm doing
here is not a guide that all influencers
YouTubers whatever they may consider
themselves to be should follow
this is just what I'm doing
so again
to recap
No Doctor Who
change to the podcast feed and any
review content which is more of a thing
for my secondary channel the break room
of Geeks as probably going to be more
limited in scope in order to avoid being
on work that is under the strike order
so what does that mean if the strike
isn't resolved come November
well it means I won't be talking about
the specials I I just won't
doesn't mean I won't watch them but I
won't talk about them and to be clear
this isn't just videos I put up here
this includes lives if you come to me on
a live stream or when I'm streaming on
Twitch and you say hey what did you
think about this movie episode of Doctor
Who whatever my answer is gonna be I
have no opinion until the strike is over
I know for folks who watch me primarily
for doctor who this is
going to be a bit of a blow
and you'll make your own call as to
whether you stick around or whether you
wait until the strike to end and then
come back because trust me once the
strike's over
I've got to come back to talk about
Doctor Who it's my favorite show I'm not
gonna stop
well not for good at any rate
but I am gonna have to stop
for now
so
that is what I found out this morning at
time of recording for you folks a couple
days ago that doctor who is considered
uh to be under the strike order and how
it is going to impact this channel if
you have any other questions that I
didn't cover in my FAQ kind of thing you
can drop those down in the comments and
I will address them to the best of my
ability
um
again please don't ask me to Give
opinions on what other people are or
aren't doing or what other people say
you should or shouldn't be doing this is
the determination that I have come to
based off the information that I have
and it is based largely off of
information that came directly from
sag-aftra if I get new information from
primary sources like that maybe things
will shift but other influencers other
reviewers other whoever or whatever they
may consider themselves to be
they'll make their own decisions these
are mine don't ask me my opinions on
what other people are doing so other
than that one feel free to ask questions
and
uh I'm gonna bring up the patreon
because depending on how I
what things I choose to address
I don't know maybe this will Branch me
out into topics that'll actually do well
for the channel or
maybe things will just start going down
in terms of engagement on the channel
the patreon is probably going to matter
more than it used to for the duration of
this if we are being completely honest
but also I'm trying to look at it as an
opportunity to maybe stretch my wings
and uh tackle some things outside my
normal wheelhouse
just for virtue of not having Doctor Who
is sort of the default fallback I mean I
had a tendency to do if there weren't
new Doctor Who episodes airing even when
I wasn't doing take two Doctor Who
reviews I used to do a Doctor Who video
a month pretty regularly it was like I
don't know what to do for this week I'll
I'll do something Doctor Who related it
was easy because it's easy for me to
talk about
I gotta figure out other stuff now
we'll see how that goes
in any case thank you for listening and
thank you for sticking around thank you
for your support
like share subscribe Bell
yay don't worry too much about it though
what I want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you're valid and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time workers of
the World Unite
thank you
[Music]
a special thanks to my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Zubin
look fulla Tarak the thing that goes
doing in the anime Ruth Oliver B
solitary pictures old Greg bogdon
Melinda Walters Jen Auntie Kate 808
Becky Sparks and I'll be likes the
poodle Robin Powell Tracy scrabot angry
Casper Adam RDO Taylor Dave Hall and
Rosalind Bentley you'll see a bunch of
other names down there as well there's
plenty of things to get on the patreon
and yeah you can hear me attempt to say
your name without embarrassing myself
check out the rewards and thank you for
everyone who supports this
[Music]
thank you